zuckerberg we're turning up the heat at
meta so employees will quit jesus what
yeah that's exactly good you really said
that go a little go zoom in facebook
parent meta
wants to cut ties with workers who can't
meet newly raised performance
expectations as a company prepares for
an economic downturn
zuck's uh
frank admission came during the q a
session with employees in which he
warned that a recent slump in the
markets might be
one of the worst downturns we've seen in
recent history this is coming from
zuckerberg realistically there are
probably a bunch of people at the
company who shouldn't be here okay can
you imagine saying that to reuters like
those of you part of my charles
sandberg's wedding you're out
part of my hope by raising expectations
and having more aggressive goals and
just kind of turning up the heat a
little bit is that i think some of you
might think that this place isn't for
you and that self-selection is okay with
me i actually love
that position he took love go a little
bit higher zuckerberg indicated that
meta plans to slow its hiring process
hiring platform engineers at least by
thirty percent roughly adding six to
seven thousand workers rather than ten
thousand it initially expected to hire
some roles that are currently empty will
stay unfilled as meta dials up pressure
on current employees you're right what
do you think about that when you hear
that what do you think about it adam i
mean you've said pretty candidly that
most companies should fire the bottom 20
percent
right i mean so the good news is if
you're in the top 80
yeah you can keep your job you know they
say warren buffett has said this before
so of other you know great luminaries in
the economy there's one way to be
recession proof or inflation proof and
that's just to be [ __ ] good at what
you do
have a straight up skill set and be good
at it if you're kind of lollygagging and
you know just there's a difference
between a job and a career if you're a
career and you become a specialist
and you're constantly improving and and
getting better and
showing loyalty to the company and you
want to be there you're not going to get
fired and if you do you'll find another
option but if you're in the bottom 20
bottom 40 percent you don't really
kind of take your job seriously
you know
again the individual responsibility
whatever would you expect to have you're
so right the top third has nothing to
worry about the middle third maybe get
nervous
the bottom third should be terrified
mm-hmm
simple as that yeah i mean
you i don't remember the number you said
exactly i don't know if it was 10 20 12
percent
30 you think that bottom 30 should be
fired
i think for every time somebody comes in
and says
you know if a boss comes in and says
these three people deserve a raise okay
cool sounds good how much of a raise are
like if you're running a real business
these three people deserve a raise
fantastic
and you got a hundred employees
and by the way this is gonna sound cold
but if you've never ran a business you
haven't operated no problem you can have
your opinion go operator business and
then you'll see what it's like when you
have to hit margins and expenses and all
these other things you deal with hey man
if you come and say we got to give these
three people a raise
and we got to hire three more people i
said great that's a great plan so tell
me which one or two people do we have to
let go
wow what do you mean well you just came
to me asking me to hire three more
people right okay and you told me to
increase the so revenues if it doesn't
match the revenue that we're growing
if you ask me to get more employees but
the revenues increase isn't at that pace
or not higher then you have to also come
up to me and say here's the two people i
also recommend we move on with oh okay
cool no problem so this is what it
should sound like a real manager should
come up and say hey tom
uh i got adam i think deserves a right
he's crushed the last two quarters i
think we need to bump him up from 80 to
92 and then i think
tyler's crushed it i think we need to
increase tyler as well and i think we
need to hire three new people uh one
engineer one bi analyst and one
processor and this is what we need to do
and then at the same time
this person that we have in this
department who's an engineer i think is
not the best called in six seven times
in the last four months
and it's usually late and the attitude
isn't necessarily there and we've asked
them up and we've sent them emails a
couple of times written them up i think
we need to let him go and this other
person that's working over here as a
processor
i don't think they like their job and
they complain to everybody and they're
very negative so i think we need to also
let those people go you approach your
boss that way the boss is going to be
like oh okay give those guys a raise and
hire those three people you know what i
would say
yeah you know what i'd say probably
you'd say i would say hey pat thank you
very much for that um obviously you
follow the nba and you know they have a
salary cap and most sports now have
salary caps
i really appreciate the way you're
managing this with the salary cap you're
trying to put the best team on the field
with the salary cap you're gonna pay
some stars and you're gonna cut some
players because you stay with the salary
cap during this economic downturn you're
gonna get a bonus at the end of the year
thank you for thinking that way because
that's the way i have to think pat with
a salary cap every day and then pat goes
up to me and goes now you're gone
because he gets the bonus
get the hell out of here i like what you
did there with the nba analogy salary
cap because it's if the salary cap is
you know 100 million dollars a year make
up a number 10 million dollars whatever
it is
that's your number that's so if you want
to hire more people and give you more
raises
somebody's got to let go now in the nba
you might say well there's a luxury tax
no there is no luxury tax that's my
point exactly you're losing money and
you can't there you go by the way it's a
hard it's back in the old days what they
call it the hard cap mm-hmm hardcast can
you imagine how many people complain
about the nba when they fire the bottom
who are not performing and they go
higher to top who are performing who
complains in the nba nobody nobody but
god forbid that's you god forbid you do
what do you think is the difference both
of them are businesses exactly exactly
both of
two points seven turnovers and uh yeah
and a technical foul it's like well
we gotta let him go
not only that how come haslam never gets
fired how come haslam has a great
attitude shows up to work everybody
shows up to work
talking to the young guy saying listen
drop those three girls be careful
getting that one pregnant
hero didn't listen and you got a couple
other people that are going through this
but you're having that conversation with
the people right he's a player coach
he's the player coach exactly you stay
on the team you were going to say
something i just i wonder on that point
if there's a layer deeper to this that
you see uh facebook this is a little old
but facebook's their their users decline
okay you're seeing elon musk buying
twitter
cleaning people out people revolting he
fired the people at spacex who spoke out
against him um you're seeing jeff bezos
have his spats with uh the the
administration i wonder if these
business owners
are starting to get sick and tired of
the inmates running the asylum and this
is a convenient excuse i wonder if
they're starting to push back and say
listen this is my company i'm tired of
the culture i'm tired of the toddlers
and babysitting all day we're gonna
clean house we're gonna make this work
you're affecting my bottom line and i'm
sick of it by the way um good point say
that's it
i support it go for it yeah i support it
because sometimes
one time it's 2013 2014.
i am afraid of losing my entire company
i as the founder ceo i am scared
i'm having panic and anxiety attacks
every night because the business is
about to go from what it is to losing
100 of people
and i'm leading through fear and i'm
walking on eggshells so i'm afraid to
challenge my guys too much because they
may leave me
and i'm afraid to set my standards and
they're now telling me how to lead
they're telling me that you should do
this you should do that you should do
this so what happens for a year and a
half
talk to jennifer and you'll see i'm like
oh my god i'm like yeah hey so you guys
are awesome also you guys are great oh
my god no no no what i'm like
i'm so sick of your like
stop
you're a leader
go back to leading if they don't want to
do anything
no problem but you're going to find the
right guys
i turn them to turn up the heat switch
my work ethic is the same it's not like
i'm not working but i raised standards
to this level
a couple of them didn't like that a
couple of them were okay with that and
couple people who were not players
went to levels that we never thought
they were gonna go to the company took
off right but sometimes a zuck or a
dorsey or anybody will go through the
fear
of man what if we lose that guy what if
we lose the scout what if we lose that
guy you know sometimes like even when
you're creating content sometimes you're
like man i can't say that because if i
say that what if we never interviewed
that guy yeah i can't say all right
because we need that guy
oh what we need
be respectful
give your thoughts
don't play games don't manipulate
don't be divisive
you know straight up show up
do your best to constantly improve
realize you don't walk on water and then
all of a sudden you're looking around
you're saying like we got some great
people around us
we have a very good environment here
people are having fun people are working
and those who don't want to work hard
and those who don't want to have fun and
those are this is not the place for you
and that's totally fine and if zuck is
going through that guess what i say to
him salute good job good for you so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]